this is a production of Cornell
University today our guest is a dr. Doug
soldat at the University of
wisconsin-madison and the soil Sciences
department there Doug does a lot of work
on soil physical properties a lot of
stuff in golf but today we're gonna get
his thoughts and some maybe some common
law issues so with that Frank I'll hand
it over to you we'll get started
thanks Carl so Carl this is our ninth
one in three weeks I'm starting to see
you on this thing more than I'm seeing
my family I so so thanks for hanging in
there with me big kudos to Carl for
keeping these going and thanks again
Doug for joining us I'm gonna yak for
about 5-10 minutes and then we're gonna
have a conversation and hopefully
provide some submitting for technical
information but much of it as a
distraction right now right I think all
of us are trying to find ways that you
know we can continue to enrich our lives
without having the normal parts of our
life available to us the things that do
enrich our lives and so I just love Joe
fern I love this guy a jury grounds he's
a blogger on turf net and I think you
know it's a good way to start to think
about it listen where our lives and
things are different and I think that
means you know it's important that we
look at things a little bit differently
and this is most important in my opinion
in the lawn and grounds area where it's
so much aesthetically driven right so
much of people walking through and look
at it look at the flowering plants there
and you know what Joe just did that I
just think is so spectacular and really
want to make a shout out to him and and
encourage you to do this this is using
Twitter and maybe there's other ways you
could do it of trying to share the
spring at his campus with with with the
students I mean what do we have these
plants here for how odd is it to see
something so beautiful that no one walks
through other than the people who care
for it it's got this eeriness to it that
maybe sharing it will help us sort of
get around that right I know for us here
in the Northeast we've been locked down
for you know several weeks
and I think you no longer you have to
have your life in modern society like
this
I think these adaptations and and
reaching out like Joe's doing is
important now if you're in the lawn care
landscape business you're just
communicating with your customers do you
have pictures of what their landscape
might have looked like in the past and
say hey you know we were able to do this
I can't get out there and do the things
I normally do right are you
communicating with your customers about
this I would say again you know we're
asking golf course superintendents to
talk to their golfers we're I asking
sports turf managers to talk to coaches
and players and community members
hey here's how we're managing this
resource while you're away it's it's
such a good time to raise your
professionalism raise your knowledge
level your standings your credibility
with your with your clientele with your
stakeholders about what you're doing
because I promise you they never see it
much of what you do is invisible until
they see a flower or maybe they see
something that they objective either way
just a quote from our new global
development chair we started a new
department here at the College of Ag as
we imagine reimagine ourselves without
the Dyson School of Business in it
anymore we don't have the AG economics
department in the College of Ag and so
we're starting to consolidate into
larger issue units and I'm in the school
of Integrative plant science and my
colleague Wendy Walford is a global
development and I just would second her
sentiment here it's I don't like talking
at a computer screen I'm much like would
would rather be walking around Brooklyn
with Doug like we were supposed to do a
few weeks ago but this is what we got
and I think sharing it together is a
really important part of moving forward
so let's see if we can distract
ourselves a little bit with grown grass
one of the things we do in addition to
these webinars is publish our weekly
newsletter we're in our 21st year of
doing it we published of course two
issues so far this year and if you'd
like to get access to it
feel free to contact Carl at that email
and he'll get you on the list
Cooperative Extension in New York State
right I'm a member to land-grant
institution here in New York and I know
the University
wisconsin-madison and Doug's turfgrass
program out there has a Cobra 19
resource area I think these kinds of
things are good to bookmark now because
overnight yesterday golf wasn't allowed
in one minute it was allowed the next
minute it wasn't landscaping was allowed
now it's altered for cosmetic purposes
so my advice to you as a professional in
his business is to find the collection
of websites you feel you can trust and
rely on this is the one Cooperative
Extension puts together as part of our
land-grant mission connected to the New
York State Department of Ag and markets
and the Dec the end the things that
impact horticulture in New York State
and agriculture in New York State would
be brought to you by these particular at
these websites here now as I said you
know the state just came out again this
morning I think it's this morning yeah
yeah it's this morning at 7:30 and I
think this is a bit of a change and
maybe it came out yesterday that
essential services landscaping is part
of it but only for pest control not
cosmetic purposes it's very interesting
right because if you look at that word
Cosmetic right Doug remember when you
and we used to talk about cosmetic use
of pesticide so right you have to now
separate are you controlling something
that's a problem or are you killing a
weed because it's cosmetic are you
controlling disease because you don't
like brown grass or is it for real now I
haven't seen any guidance on this and we
can talk about this later as we move
along but it does raise some questions
if you're interested in thinking about
it now in the lawn and grounds area
there's some there's some good local
resources right the new york state
school facilities management association
did a survey on school districts i
talked about a little bit yesterday with
the sports turf guys because you know
you got sports turf guys in schools and
the survey would about 80 respondents is
saying yeah some people have no
maintenance staff out at all some are at
full or near some are limited some are
just doing emergencies i think it's good
to keep your eye on this because it
helps you communicate
to your administrators if they're saying
hey um you know how can we manage the
Cornell campus with five guys down or do
I need you know twenty guys or forty
guys so so what are other people doing I
think it's a critical part of the
discussion and of course our director
grounds here Dan shied she said you know
it made a shout-out to his professional
organization I would say a leading
organization in the grounds area
professional grounds management society
has an excellent kovat information site
and if you dig a little bit you can see
it right you click on that red cross
you'll get to another document that
gives you good information about what
other guys are doing see one of the
things that's important at this time is
there's many ways to skin this cat each
of us knows how we have to communicate
to people about what's going on it's
important that you get good guidance
right you don't have to go at it alone
you don't have to reinvent the wheel but
you could tailor what other people are
doing for your benefit right and the
landscape industry as we talked about
the enna nal P has done a really good
job here as well all right let's look at
some weather we do to weather a little
bit this was the soil temperature when
we were chatting just a few days ago
last week and here's what it looks like
now now you can see in the metropolitan
New York area we're actively moving into
the low to mid 50s now we're going to
see what's going to happen this week but
right now we're in the low to mid 50s
and in the upper 30s 40s throughout the
rest of the northeastern United States
what about growing degree days this was
the difference from last year last week
and here it is this week now a lot of it
is blank in this picture because we
hadn't generated any degree days yet and
now that we have you can see the
majority of upstate New York is 2 to 3
weeks behind normal in degree days this
is the 30 year average right and only to
the south well south of the metropolitan
area right you look well south here of
the new year here's the New York
metropolitan area you draw a line and
you go south you can see it's much
warmer down here and you get into these
areas you know and you're 2 to 3 weeks
behind and
we're expecting this was last week's
projection where it was last week's this
is this week's look at how little this
is changing as I toggle back and forth
right yes you're only generating a
single digit single digit growing degree
days in this area here and now you're
still only generating maybe early double
digit in the metro area you've got to go
to South Jersey to get in here and you
know you're basically not accumulating
much at all we had some snow in Ithaca
today all right oops sorry about that
all right so what does this mean how do
we put this in perspective what is it
how is the grass growing well you know
we've learned a lot about track and
grass growth over the last decade or at
least brought back a lot of our thinking
with regard to grass growth over the
last decade and fundamentally this isn't
a bad rule of thumb to think about is
when the temperature is roughly in the
mid to upper 60s cool season grasses
photosynthesize at their maximum rate
right and so when you're less than that
you're some percentage of all how the
plant could grow and if you look at an
average temperature of 50 degrees which
we're barely going to be at until the
middle the end the next week we're less
than 25% we're less than 25% of what
possibly a grass could grow at this time
right less than 25% so this informs me
right now that the grass doesn't want to
grow very much and if I'm limited on
resources I don't want it to grow I look
at the slowing spring as a gift to us in
the northeastern United States to slow
the landscape from progressing because
if we can't get into it and tend to it
with what just the bare minimum things
it's gonna really get out of hand
quickly if we can't get back to the
landscape until June or July so there's
no need to promote anything right now
right in my opinion unless you want to
fight weeds if you've got a really thin
turf that's a different story so the way
to start doing this
driving back your regular inputs just
think about the thing you spend the most
time doing and that's mullet and again
the key here is to raise your mowing
height right if you normally are keeping
your lawns at 2 inches right by raising
them you know that means you've got to
cut them when they're at 3 inches which
means you're tied to once a week by
raising them an inch it allows you by
following the mow 30 rule the old
hashtag mo 30 rule which is never remove
more than 30 percent of the leaf tissue
in a single mowing you can keep you can
mow when it's four and a half and that
gives you ten days you can go to four
and now you're every two weeks now in
the springtime when we get a growth
surge right when we see that surge and
growth in the spring time right
it may get tighter even at a higher
mowing height but over the long term it
will always require less mowing if you
raise the height of cut so this should
be your first move this should be your
first move now as I wrap up right the
next thing the lawn landscape is
thinking about it weeds and I'm sure
everybody's thinking I gotta get the
priests out I said not the priests well
I got to get those present roll I got
dandelion what I got these weeds okay
listen we don't know what we can do I
don't know how the state's gonna feel
about some of these things we want to be
careful with the way we deploy our works
force apply chemicals be strategic about
it so why don't we take a minute and
look at weeds we may have chronic
problems with and what they indicate
because in many cases if you got along
like this in better shape right
it wouldn't have as many weeds maybe if
you just mowed it once in a while add as
many weeds but you want to be careful
because if we can't mow for a while and
you have a thin weedy lawn this is what
it looks like when you don't mow it but
look at one of the common problems
that's there amongst what causes all
these
thin lawns lots of weed eNOS look at
this look at how much the word soil
shows up in that particular in this
particular way of looking the way weeds
invade lawns right so let's as we
transition to our topic for today about
soils right it's not uncommon to see a
really compacted clay soil in a lawn not
doing well and if you have marginal
growing conditions or you're still
waiting to green up it could take longer
and to do well and stay thin and then
fill with weeds later in the year this
looks like on the left here a ripe area
for crabgrass to invade right a surface
feeder doesn't need to get very deep
it's perfectly happy to live in the mat
that you leave there and all you need is
a halfway decent soil was very little
inputs and you can get yourself a good
lawn there oh yeah right you know I'm
not you know I don't think fertilizer is
gonna fit this you could people say all
you need a soil test look at this scene
you saw test I said well I don't know
you need a soil test yeah you need to
figure out how to loosen it up I don't
know what you need to test if you can
maybe you should crack your chief it you
can crack your head on it or it'll break
open some cement or something but you
can see the foot tracks and everything
else that contribute to these things so
then we see this situation right it's
very cognizant all right you know I
don't think many turf managers ever see
a problem they don't think to poke in a
hole and it won't fix it I'm concern and
bleat would bleach it cleans everything
in air fication fixes everything but
what do we know about what the benefits
of cultivation are and this is from our
sports turf management website right the
benefits of cultivation are short-lived
they generally have to be done
frequently high-traffic areas where you
have compacted soils six to eight times
per year it could be a site now Doug and
I'll discuss this this may be outlandish
but a suggesting quarry schedule could
entail spring and fall with
fertilization like coring in the summer
early fall and then keeping them open to
take advantage of freezing and thawing
if you really have a compacted native
soil right and so the question sometimes
come up alright I often hear I you
should so I'll pass
so here is the young turfgrass
professional here and a much younger
rube days pushing a spreader right
talking about the three properties of
soils right physical chemical and
biological right and Doug uses this in a
lot of his training and so we'll talk
about lawn soil management and the first
question and I think Carl now's a good
time to ask it which property is usually
the cause of most of the issues that we
see in in the lawn right let's just take
a minute and be a little interactive
here what which property is usually the
cost because you know typically somebody
will look at this picture right and say
oh yeah I gotta test the soil right I
gotta test the soil and then come back
with a fertilizer recommendation and
maybe you know Doug can tell me I'm
crazy but I think I see it enough that
oh yeah I should do a soil test which
says okay now I'm gonna come back and
I'm gonna talk to you about chemical
properties wait a minute is that the
kind of testing I should have been doing
so Carl what do we got for answers now
are we getting some sharing yes so we've
got um so far about half the people
voted we got 84 percent saying physical
properties nobody yet has said chemical
properties and then 16% biological
properties excellent excellent
so I think that's my last slide but I
want to go back and keep these pictures
up there I want to look at you guys a
little bit now so Carl let's keep in
mind these pictures because then they
can we can look at the three of us and
not just stare at slides huh let's make
sure we get to these do I need the
fertilized dog should i Arif I and what
about compost so let me stop sharing
here we can look at each other so the
survey said physical and biological
properties dog nobody said chemical
properties and I think that's got to be
because you've been very effective in
getting that message out and I think in
urban areas it's very obvious right you
know so physical properties and heavily
built environments tend to have more
problems than
and chemical properties but why don't we
start there is that true in your mind
yeah for sure I mean
so our research station Oh Jane or here
in Madison we do lawn trials all the
time and we find you know you can
maintain grass in a good-looking
good-looking grass easily without a lot
of inputs and then we go just a mile
away to suburbia and if we try to impose
those same treatments on a lawn there
it's not gonna work at all and the
differences are our egg Research Station
is built on a nice thick silt loam that
used to be growing corn and you move
into the urban environment and it's 2
inches of topsoil then compacted clay so
that that's what we've learned over the
years and it's it's obvious and looks
like the participants here know it too
ISM physical properties are the thing
like if you don't have a healthy soil
you got a hat you got a your the amount
of inputs you need to maintain what we
consider acceptable skyrocket so what do
you make of the comments about
biological properties right I think
we've begun to use the word soil health
a lot and certainly to me certainly at
Cornell wheel of soil health at Cornell
so so but to me it sort of implies more
of the biological properties are
considered one of the things I have
taken from all the years of being near
soil guys like you is that the physical
and biological properties are going to
be very intimately linked right I mean
is that a fair statement that if you're
growing healthy plants and you've
probably got a good physical soil that
you've probably got a good biological
life do you ever see lots of biological
life in crappy soils too no you said it
perfectly they're linked and in the in
the the horse is the physical properties
and the cart is the biological so and
it's all it's all organic matter and air
water balance right so if you have if
you have a lot of organic matter a nice
mix of a good pore space the biology is
gonna follow you look at all the science
that's been done and now we don't know
you know the thing that the the people
like Paul Koch and the you know the the
plant pathologists are working on it's
like there's millions of organisms we
don't know the first thing
about and they're trying to figure out
how they interact together but if you
just look at the amount of organisms and
biological activity those are driven
purely by organic matter and soil
physical health so you get those things
right and the biology which we don't
really understand will follow you know
and maybe 10 20 30 years down the line
we can start doing testing to see if
your biology is a little out of whack
but right now we just get those physical
properties right your biology is gonna
be fine okay so perfect so we set the
stage we teed up the ball I got to work
on physical properties I can sell
aeration shirred a lawn be routinely
arif I'd period okay that's my question
shuttle lon soil be routinely air fun it
it depends it's so you said it perfectly
it's it's a it's a band-aid you got to
do it consistently in traffic soils and
so like when I see a native let's let's
use like an athletic field or something
yeah you're gonna to keep that thing
viable you're gonna have to Arif I at
six to eight times because the soil
can't handle the traffic that's being
imposed on it okay so what should you do
in that case you should probably be
looking at doing a sand cap you should
be looking for solutions to the
compaction the aeration that I think
really what you're doing is just
preparing a seedbed so you can over seat
it more effectively but a lawn how many
I verified I've lived in a suburban area
for fifteen sixteen years now I verified
once and I think that was I don't know
why I did it maybe now you know I gotta
say right I mean okay so let's let's
what's okay so routinely for a soil
that's sustaining a halfway decent lawn
that that you know what are we doing I'm
worried about weeds coming up now I'm
doing it when I don't have to especially
in the spring with crabgrass if I you
know don't do what I have to do but if I
have a thin lawn and I've got a heavy
clay soil and you guys are now telling
me I should get those physical
properties that I shouldn't sell my weed
and
I should tell them a physical property
program so physical property improvement
program what's the strategy and that
leads to my question about compost you
know I didn't cap a lawn so let's talk
about what a grounds manager or lawn
care provider would would talk to their
customers about fixing some of these
areas that can't sustain a lawn well
right yeah so you know the ideally what
you do is incorporate compost into the
profile with like a tillage implement
and reseed it but that's that's
basically impossible in almost all
situations because you have buried
utilities right and then who wants to
reestablish lon so something I first
worked on when I was a student at
Cornell in the in the 2000s was applying
layers of compost on top of lawns and we
did that in in Rochester at Buffalo and
I think down in Long Island and we found
after about three years of putting a
quarter inch down in the spring and a
quarter inch down in the fall that we
massively improved those soil physical
properties in in the Long Island site
there's a high school field the physical
property is improved but the the field
was too heavily trafficked so it's not
if you have too much traffic and that in
that picture you showed with all the
dead grass like outside the door nothing
you can't you got to build a sand-based
root zone for that I mean you get your
compost in the world's not gonna fix it
you have thought you have to manage your
traffic but if the traffic is right
adding compost is gonna dramatically fix
a crappy soil and then we've done that
we took that research over here to
Wisconsin found the same thing quarter
inch in the spring quarter inch in the
fall you do that for three years and by
the end of the three year period you're
done you've actually you've improved
that root zone enough where you can you
can lower your inputs dramatically so
what kind of compost because you did the
bio solid work here at Cornell and I
believe you're recommending a different
source because of the potential you know
and I hear put a quarter inch of compost
and I'm thinking man I remember when
Marty did that when you were
my dad wasn't that like 500 times the
amount of pee we needed or then let the
runoff problem so can you separate cuz
okay I like what you're saying I can
core maybe and then put the compost on
and if I do it a little you know all at
once I'm set for a while
what kind of compost yeah that's a
that's a good point so the compost we
use in New York were poultry and dairy
manure compost from the agriculture
industry and those things come loaded
with phosphorus and and some nitrogen to
what we did in Wisconsin though is
because we knew there was a negative
result from that we elevated the soil
phosphorus levels in the in that New
York study to to the levels I think that
I think the Cornell soil lab said we
haven't seen levels as high I think is a
thousand like twelve twelve hundred in
some cases weird like the optimum is
like five you know so we worry we
worried about the environmental impact
of that and so in a lower phosphorus
source compost will be like a municipal
yard waste compost the leaves and the
grass clippings and the good news is
that that stuff's even easier to find so
you know use a use a municipal compost
like give it away here in Dane County
where I live
hi make sure it's high quality you don't
want any debris in there that's gonna
you know cut people's feet or mess up
your mowers but that's low enough and
phosphorus where you're just getting the
physical benefit and not all the extra
nutrients so we've got a few minutes
left
should I be fertilizing my lawn in the
northern climates you spent enough time
in New York you know we're pretty
similar to the way you are maybe just a
week ahead more so in the urban areas
much like you'd be in Milwaukee and in
downtown Madison so again you know the
the reflex action that you and I did we
all talked about the first week we did
the golf session together is there a
need to put some fertilizer down in your
mind on lawns I I don't think I mean
we're always saying that that you want
to wait until here like you said a
similar climate wait till Memorial Day
because what you're seeing right now is
you see a lot of real I'm
get out my window there's not been
fertilization going on I see a lot of
bright green grass that's the
microorganisms in the soil that died
over winter they're decaying the soil
temperatures are getting that 50-point
like you said it's warm enough where
there's a there is some nitrogen there
from for them to survive on and in in
that by that that'll double sustain the
plant through about Memorial Day and
that's why we recommend holding off on
that early fertilization especially in
these conditions where you don't want to
be mowing and growing more grass than
you need to this is a time to think
about maybe maybe waiting a bit
excellent Carl
questions yeah we got one from pile
working suggesting about vermicompost
what do you think about vermicompost
yeah I don't I haven't worked with
vermicompost I know I know it's really
popular for for gardeners to use I think
I think it's it's probably great I you
know though the main thing you want to
do is is get a get a test on the
phosphorus level if the phosphorus
levels are reasonable it's it's likely
gonna be a great source I think the
vermicompost the Kyle you probably know
more about this than I do
but they're they're processing though
through the gut the earthworm and and
making a really nutrient-rich product
there so as long as it's it's relatively
low in phosphorus the nitrogen could be
a huge benefit hey Carl can we give Kyle
a mic Kyle you got a mic cuz you know
there was a product release the number
of years ago in the professional turf
market called worm power there's a
number of these vermicompost asila T's
coming online I think they make a lot of
sense in many ways but Kyle you want to
talk a little bit about what you think
yeah we know about things like worm
power for improving soil function sure
yeah it's a really interesting topic
Doug just very very timely I think and
you know my question was cuz I can't
really recall how rich some of those
vermicompost are and P but I know that
if you can get some of the the sources
that are coming from the same original
compost inputs like a worm power comes
from dairy inputs with a nutritionist on
staff so they know exactly what the
chemist
the inputs are so I think you can get
really stable fertility ratios in them
but I'm just not sure how high they are
in some of those nutrients that that's
what something I think we would have to
check into on that I think the I guess
the thing I would say is that when you
get into those commercial products like
that I mean we're talking you need a
massive amount of material to get a
quarter-inch down so I gravitate towards
the how much is you know can I get the
free stuff and then can I get this stuff
where they cook where they charge me
five dollars for a pickup load but when
you start seeing things like you know
with name brands on them they become
cost prohibitive and they start saying
oh just spray this little liquid
solution down and at you know four
ounces per acre and then it's gonna
magically improve your soil problem no
no no you want to put down a lot of
stuff so Carl I grab the screen if you
don't mind this is what we're talking
about worm power this is you know a lot
of people in the golf course business
use this thing we're not promoting and
of course they have the you know the the
response and that's reduction in rooting
pictures seemed very interesting and
believable and then you come down here
you know and you see the nutrition is
virtually non-existent
so what I'll say about this though this
is compost tea this is a liquid right
we're powers of liquid I'm talking about
putting down the compost oh right solid
stuff don't they sell a solid - Kyle do
they sell a solid - yeah they they did
before and therefore their other version
before they change they had a they they
would screen at for time op
dressing-down Gulf and they had a larger
particulate but you know one point that
Doug made about the municipal composts
there are a lot of smaller companies now
that seem to be doing vermicompost hang
out of municipal compost sources so that
may give you some of that consistency in
the material that you don't always have
with municipal sources but that might be
worth looking into for something like
this excellent all right Carl another
question yeah we got a couple questions
I did want to just touch briefly on Doug
was mentioning this is a lot of material
you look at a quarter inch over a
thousand square feet that's
three-quarters of a cubic yard just four
a thousand square feet so once you start
getting into some some bigger lawns that
becomes a lot of material don't think
this is something that you're
necessarily going to be doing now but if
conditions warrant maybe hey it's time
to start over this is a chance to
rejuvenate this is a strategy maybe for
doing it yeah
so do have a couple questions and other
materials Kathy mentions Melora tonight
Gary was saying biochar maybe you could
just briefly touch on what those are and
those are options or I've contributed to
milorganite during my days there in
Wisconsin in fact one time when I was in
Milwaukee doing Master Gardener they
shut the water plant down for a few
hours and I got Cryptosporidium that I
still keep with me to this day and boy
did I contribute there for a week to the
milorganite plant yeah thank you very
much I actually thought it was a
conspiracy we made big joke about it
anyway milorganite is an organic
fertilizer Doug sounds like a good idea
let's start with that one
yeah well orgonites it's a it's made
from this that we used to call sewage
sludge from city Milwaukee now we call
BAU solids but again so it's all the
thing we're talking about it's a it's
reusing something we used to call waste
that now has a different use so it was
developed a fertilized turf grass it's
great but it's no different it's it
provides six percent nitrogen two
percent phosphorus and no potassium in
in the big scheme it's no different than
a it's just a fertilizer from a
different source and it's an effective
one but in terms of fixing the physical
properties no no no fix or the physical
properties add in milorganite no dial
char is really cool it's it's basically
charcoal you take you take a woody
material and you burn it at low oxygen
and you basically make charcoal and it's
got really unique physical and chemical
properties and specifically it can
stabilize the organic matter and keep
your organic matter levels high can
minimize leaching it hasn't been around
long enough for us to really know how to
best utilize it but it's still something
that people are
playing around with and if you have a
source of biochar I can't see a lot of
negatives to people playing around with
it and using it I do think it's gonna be
more expensive again a lot of this
physical stuff you got to put down a lot
of material so anytime you start saying
hey Spray this liquid solution at four
ounces per acre I start saying yeah
that's not gonna do anything for
physical it's the same thing the biochar
just sprinkling on fairy dust it might
be the best stuff in the world but if
you're not putting down a lot of it it
probably isn't gonna help
so loic's low-cost large volume that's
the best way to handle soil physical
properties and maybe Frank we can end on
one last question because a good one to
end on Michael's asking from the Midwest
air fine question cord coring is less
likely for him and harder to do than
solid tine is solid tine okay question
and I'd be happy I'd love to hear what
Doug says I was chatting about this with
the big guy in Nebraska yesterday
raucous waah that one of the things we
like about a solid tine operation often
times is if you can get it deep enough
and it gives you some of that kick in
shattering that in a native soil system
if you've got a compacted soil like
we've been talking about some shattering
from a solid time to me is better than
pulling a car and bringing up soil that
are then I've got to deal with some
other way if I feel like I can do to
soil at the right moisture content and a
lot of it is going to be based on
moisture content then I'm a little fond
of more fracturing than I feel like I
want to pull up a core but I want to
hear what what the resident soil
scientist yeah you know I was thinking
about the other big guy Marty Petrovic I
think this is what he did his PhD on
Michigan State and I in my perspective
is the counterpoint is I think if you do
it enough you're eventually gonna create
a hard pan layer even if you are
fracturing and you get some that benefit
I worry that consistent use of that on a
native soil you're packing that material
down I love it in sand I love it and
saying because sandy can't compact it
just pushes the sand to the side but in
a native soil with clay content I worry
that you're gonna get a layer event
okay so what happens if I can put a time
with a point on it and go in and kick
back and go out and go in yeah back and
go out that's what I'm thinking about
versus going in and coming out with a
core right yeah I said I think you can
do it there if so physical research is
just slim pickins - I mean cuz measuring
these things is hard that the way that
we can measure the benefit of that is
difficult to do because the way water
flows through pore spaces but yeah I
would vary it I would be very in my time
width I'd be wearing the depth I like
the kick right but we just don't have a
lot of evidence to be like yeah this is
that this is the thing you got now now
lawns lawns one of the problems I got
with use general Arif ocation of lawns
is the drum rollers don't go deep no the
one we're using the Billy Goat is a
vertical drive but I feel like I have to
go over the lawn multiple times to even
impact a few percentage points of the
surface so before we wrap up Doug let's
just have a minute about you know if I
got a drum that goes yo deep versus a
time that I can get four inches deep or
two inches deep or variable depth deep
which do I want yeah you I've talked to
the the lawn guys about this like why do
you use these crappy air fires and and
and guys who've been in golf and they
know they know that these things don't
do a lot of good it's like just do one
you're gonna hit a rock and it's gonna
flip the machine over so I you know I
think in when we know that the soil is
good and there's no rocks in it or no
compact massively compacted layers those
deeper vertical penetration tools work
but in reality with the landscapes and
you know we're in a glacial both of us
are sitting in glacial ated landscapes
with rocks near the surface I get moved
up by frost heaving every year you hit
you hit a rock and you're outta
commission for the day so you know
that's why my recommendation is build up
the soil with compost to create a new
route so
rather than trying to fix the crap
that's under there with with deep dining
or vertical shaft aeration well that
seems like a perfect place to end on
physical properties and the long-term
challenges that they create when you
can't just kill it in all the things
that make that hard to do Doug so great
to see you pal take care of yourself
Carl I'll pass it back to you we're done
for the day we just made it at 39 here
you go yeah and there's a couple more
questions but I'm going to keep those
for other sessions too you know a couple
good questions and mulching leaves and
stuff this week that's right yeah again
thanks to Doug and for jumping on here
thanks Kyle minutes and we'll see you
guys next week good to see you all guys
take care see you guys this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu